[Music]
Luigi's invited to a gorgeous hotel with
Mario peach and the others oh lucky him
Luigi's mansions free this hotel is much
more than meets the eye for not long
after Luigi arrives things take a dark
turn we begin our tour by taking in some
sights and sounds you may never leave
one to leave the other guests certainly
don't plan to move on their ghosts after
all and their rather aggressive simply
scare them with the strobe of them up
Luigi's new Poltergust g00
has the powerful suction capabilities
required and other new features as well
first the slab while trapping a ghost
slam it on the ground to inflict some
damage it helps to get other ghosts in
on the action
next the suction shocked
finally the plunger to attach it to
something then pull the string and you
can destroy furniture and more it's
effective against certain co-stars too
[Music]
sometimes ghosts may feel inclined to
hang up on you
in such situations of first trip to the
powerful air pressure with these 12 blow
away ghosts and it's perfect for when
you need a little air we simply can't
overlook the latest invention from
Professor egad namely GUI G changed
between Luigi and GUI G to use both
their skills GUI G can do everything
from slipping through metal fences to
walking on spikes indeed there are
obstacles too great for the region to
handle on its own and if you pass a toy
con controller to a friend he makes for
a great co-op partner but proceed with
caution
GUI G and water definitely don't mix now
please direct your attention to the
scare scraper spooky shoe if it also
houses of two eight figures for local or
online co-op gameplay defeat all ghosts
before time runs out seek and find our
deal
this place toes and face any challenges
the tower throws at you what a place to
wake up in a haunted hotel with floor
after floor of oddities many traps and
mischievous ghosts lurk within what will
befall our missing Mario and Friends and
his dear brother Luigi their fate rests
in your
[Music]
Luigi's Mansion 3
[Music]
you
[Music]